YOUNG PLAY
THIS AFTERNOON.
>> Ed: DEVILS HAVE THE CONTROLS
TO START THE GAME.
LOSING IT.
WORKED UP ALONG TO MERCER.
KEVIN  OVERTIME
DEFEAT YESTERDAY AGAINST
CAROLINA.
>>OD TO SEE NOLAN FOOTE
WITH AN OPPORTUNITITEW
JERSEY HAMMOND IN
DEVILS PLAYING WITHCK.
>> Ken: GOOD TO SEE JESPER BRATT
IN THE  DEFLECTED A FEW SHOTSIN.
HE TRIED TO CONTROL THAT PUCK
OFF THE WALL AND 69 PO
LITTLE  RASMUSSEN.
MICHAEL
LOOK AT THE CHANCES.
DEVILS GET A POWER PLAY. THE DE
>> Ken: ERNE GOT IN BEHIND THE
DEVILS DEFENSE THERE.
THE PUCK NOT COMPLETELY ON THE
TAPE OR THAT W IN FRONT.
HAMMOND KICKS IT OUT.
IT WENT OFF HIS SKATE BUT
HAMMOND, GOOD
YOU NEED MORE CHANCES IN SHOTS
THAN YOU HAVE
THIS IS THE PATIENCE I WANT TO
SEE FROM THE DEVILS AGAINSAN SH.
KNOCKED AWAY BY NEDELJKOVIC.
SHARANGOVICH HOLDS.
FINAL 46 SECONDS.
INONT.
BETTER LOOK HERE.
LINDSTROM.
SOMEHOW PAST NEDELJKOVIC FROM AO
HE
DEVILS STANDS.
>> Referee: AFTER COACH'S
SO MUCH SUCCESS.
UND AT THE SKA
>> Ken: YOU GOT TO BURY THESE
DEVILS GET A BREAK THERE.
PAVEL ZACHA IS TRYING DETROIT.
HRONEK FOR
KUOKKANEN.
HAMMOND A BIG SAVE OFF BERTUZZI
ONT.
DeKEYSER THROWS IT ON NET.
TRAFFIC IN FRONT!
IT TRICKLES IN!
I DON'T THINK GRAVES PUSHED ERNE
IN THERE.
HE GETS BODY POSITION.
THEY ARE
IS OVERTURNED.
WE HAVE NO GOAL.WAY.
NET IS  USES HIS BIG FRAME
ALONG THE WALL AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, IT'S OFF
NOTHING GOING.
>> Ed: ERNE HAS THESMUSSEN IS T
THIS ONE.
EASY GOAL HERE.
YOU